better results with less money that's
the aim of the EU s reformed cohesion
policy 325 billion euros had to be set
aside for the next seven years but is it
enough to boost growth and create jobs
in the regions will the reform bring
about the desired changes or will a
reduction of the budget have a serious
impact on regional policies we ask Dutch
MEP Lambert fenestella Roy and Greek mep
nikos chrysalis is it really necessary
to reform cohesion policy times have
changed we are in a deep crisis and now
we have targeted for growth knowledge
for greener production sustainability
and jobs that's why we had to change it
in a very very tough way it's kadesha p
rehan and shot it has met exit on cratan
my long catan periphery on Oh potty poll
kisne his net loss upper edit FL leg out
the steamer near poachy in an ERG a loop
and this one case of the brand acronym
well the reduction of the budget have
serious consequences for regional
policies I don't think so immediately
because we now use new methods for
instance we give loans and we give
guarantees by which we bring the banks
in for their part and this is necessary
for the way out of the crisis edik a
Samaritan approach it's chris's apetito
ave ste propellers mulligan appendices
Getty of Rebecca's por problemas en
appendices n n dot s atacado propor legs
mon appendices den in a leaky TKS PCC
spittle porn how can a bigger impact
from the available funding be achieved
now the money will be spent in another
way we ask every country to come up with
some specializations that are important
in the regions and we combine those
initiatives we call it smart
specialisation so that we have a better
use of our human capacities our
knowledge throughout Europe and we can
speed up also in Eastern Europe in
southern Europe the way out of the
crisis I Mexica to F ro Torah / so drop
opete prep fa takato efron la Penna son
meep alipio sofa troppo name is Pat
Allison lawmen panna circuit appear me
me me telly yawns I'll take a afro
stance many PO he